[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
é
hangu
de brinde a as destiladas pelo lar
encerrado
você
[Música]
o que você de ser expulso eu digo venha
vamos juntos pois pra mim ainda da clan
são bem suaves os comandos dessa nave
sempre começa na clave triangular a
decolagem é um pouco mal disse afogar na
claridade perceberam pouco tarde e em
querer tudo o que muito da
[Música]
ocupou que se controla boto manifesta
comunhão existe em todo coração
exemplares da verdade quanto sem vaidade
transcende a desigualdade com minutos
e é no meu corpo que esse encontro algo
torto manifesta comunhão exigem todo
coração exemplares da perda quando sem
vaidade transcende a desigualdade cuba
o liga nem ii
os
[Música]
ei
- meu corpo que se encontrou algo torto
manifesta comunhão exigem todo o coração
exemplares da verdade quando sem vaidade
transcende a desigualdade de combinando
em
e é no meu corpo que se encontra logo
tudo manifesta comunhão e exigem todo
coração exemplares é verdade quando sem
vaidade transcende a desigualdade cup
dão bem
a fuga
[Música]
i e ii
e quem aprendeu canta comigo vamos lá
[Música]
mas a
[Aplausos]
as árvores do cerrado experimentam o
gosto da morte sem perder a vida e
passam a maior parte do tempo mas mortas
do que vivas e vivem tanto tempo em
relação ao nosso tempo
animadas apenas pelo vento
[Música]
ah
o papel
[Música]
sou um bicho do cerrado quer nos dizer
nasce a festa é na escolhinha e adam e
daqui e vou sair
sou um bicho do senar um cinzel nassim
essas terras gripe a
não vou sair
posso ir ao mundo inteiro mais pra cá eu
vou voltar
não importa o dinheiro será cuidar o meu
corpo é de bocha o meu sangue água moura
ae
sua taxa muito a cultura nem caçada da
rainha
romarinho e cavalhada
o estado de inoperância de troca ea
congada
sou um bicho do cerrado entrar com os
diesel na se essas terras escolhia e
daqui não vou sair
a tribo nou da humanidade merece mais
atenção e o mapa da diversidade precisa
bons proteção cachoeira rio bouro quem
nos paga 11 baga em cerrado pede isso o
povo protejam seus animais com ser
pintada lobo-guará jaguatirica e
ariranha taco paca e tamanduá nado
cuidado ea piranha
o teu amor pra [ __ ]
ah
sou um bicho de será você
essas
quem tá bom sair mas o o bicho de
encenar a água entrava ou diesel na se
essas guerras guiado idade
não vou sair encerrada é diferente tudo
quanto é lugar tenha seca ea enchente a
guru pra respirar ares bem ea torcida de
toda a copa américa sendo o nosso amor
sou lixo de encerrar entre arcos eu
nasci
essas terras mulher
na bolsa e vem sou um bicho do será
entre arbustos eu né
essas terras boi criar unidades móoca tá
comigo sou juros
[Música]
a setas que criá lo
[Aplausos]
[Música]